to Ukraine now where heavy fighting
continues Ukrainian forces have attacked
Russian occupied mellitoppel a strategic
important city in the Southeast at least
two people have died meanwhile Ukrainian
authorities say Russian attacks on the
port city of Odessa have left 1.5
million people without power present for
Vladimir zielinski says strikes by
iranian-made drones hit two energy
facilities destroying the power Network
in the region
the situation in the Odessa region is
very difficult after a night of strikes
by Iranian drones Odessa and other
cities and villages in the region are in
the dark
more than one and a half million people
in the Odessa region are without
electricity
only critical infrastructure is
connected and to the extent where it is
possible to supply electricity
and heavy fighting is also ongoing in
Ukraine's Eastern Donetsk region both
sides have reported significant losses
some of the fiercest battles are near
the city of bakmud it's sustained
widespread damage and people still
living there are facing tough winter
conditions
speed is of the essence lud Miller
Beeler distributes water and food for
air raid shelters in bakmut
much of the Frontline City in the
Donetsk region is in ruins the few who
get stoves for the winter are the lucky
ones
it's unbearable it cold and there aren't
any blankets
agrees above freezing in the house
sometimes Lord Miller and the team
managed to create a little Joy amid the
horror
a week ago she rescued a boy and brought
him to her family
now she's been able to bring his mother
to
I have a present for you let's call that
to Mama really loud
the Russian defense Ministry has
released pictures of young reservists
being transferred to the front equipped
with new rifles and winterized uniforms
is meant to push back at widespread
reports that reservists are in fact
poorly equipped and just used as Caden
fodder in Ukraine
here the outskirts of Donetsk on the
Russian occupied side of the front again
no electricity in water rocket fire is
constant
I don't want anything anymore not riches
or other Pleasures just to go to bed and
wake up in peace not like now when I
wake up I see all the horror before my
eyes
another night awaits full of Rocket fire
and destruction raining from the sky